Speaker 1: All right, we have two positive
Donald Trump stories today, they are good
stories, they are things that are good for
the left.
They are things that are good for the country.
They are things that are good for the world
and for everything that is good.
The first one is Monday.
You might remember I told you that Donald
Trump filed before a judge named Tanya Chunkin
had even made a decision about Donald Trump's
first request to block documents and records
related to his activities leading up to the
Trump riots from being sent to the committee
investigating the Trump riots before the judge
even ruled on the first one.
Donald Trump already submitted a second request,
saying, No, no, no, you got it.
Here's another reason why you should block
this stuff.
And I told you on Monday.
We are waiting for a decision from Judge Tanya
Fratkin.
We now have gotten a decision.
I guess we would call it the first decision,
and the decision is the correct one.
It's a good one.
And it is that Judge Chunkin has denied Donald
Trump's attempt to withhold records from the
January 6th Committee, to put it very simply,
as CNN explains.
A federal judge will allow the U.S. House
to access hundreds of pages of documents from
Donald Trump's presidency leading up to and
about the Jan. six attack at the U.S. Capitol,
in a forceful rejection of Trump's recent
attempts to control information from his White
House.
The ruling Tuesday night from Judge Tanya
Fratkin of the U.S. District Court in D.C.
is a blow to Trump's efforts to keep more
than 700 pages of records from the White House
secret.
Though his legal team has informed the court
it intends to appeal.
Presidents are not kings and plaintiff is
not president.
A very interesting final page from the decision,
which you can easily find online.
Judge Chut writes.
Accordingly, the court holds that the public
interest lies in permitting the combined will
of the legislative and executive branches
to study the events that led to and occurred
on Jan. six, and to consider legislation to
prevent such events from occurring again.
Judge Judkins conclusion is for the reasons
explained above.
The court will deny plaintiffs request to
enjoin defendants from enforcing or complying
with the select committees.
Aug. 25, 2021 Requests Because Plaintiff is
unlikely to succeed on the merits of his claims
or suffer irreparable harm, and because the
balance of the equities and public interest
bear against granting his requested relief.
So the let's go back to the CNN article.
As of now, the National Archives remains on
track to turn over to the house a number of
documents Friday.
Now I've told you before, this includes White
House call logs and video logs.
Who was Trump speaking to in those days leading
up to the riots and schedules related to January
six?
Who was Trump meeting with at the White House,
as well as three pages of handwritten notes
from Trump's then chief of staff?
The outcome in court also could help the house
in its pursuit of more information from those
around Trump, including witnesses who haven't
been subpoenaed and haven't spoken to the
committee yet.
What that means is knowing who Trump spoke
to.
Knowing who Trump met with will give the House
investigators more information about, Hey,
here are people Trump spoke to.
Let's go and talk to them.
Let's subpoena them.
Let's request their records now.
Important note two important notes, I guess
I would say one scheduled for release Friday
to the committee.
So there's two things there.
One scheduled for release Friday.
It's only Wednesday.
Between now and then.
Donald Trump may try more funny business and
he, his lawyers, saying that they're going
to make another appeal.
So will the documents actually be released
to the House Committee Friday?
We don't yet really know.
The second part is released to the committee,
and I'm continuing to get emails from folks
understandably excited about these documents,
saying When are we going to see them?
We may never see them because again it is
released to the committee, released to the
committee and documents sometimes leak and
sometimes are deliberately leaked.
It's completely conceivable that by next Monday,
we will have a leaked call log of the people
Trump spoke to, or a visitor log of the people
Trump met with in the days leading up to the
Jan. six riots.
At the same time, that's not actually what
is at issue here.
This is about releasing these documents to
the committee, not to the public.
Last thing?
This will probably not come as a surprise
to you.
But well, so this part may be a surprise to
you, the judge here, Judge Tanya Chunkin,
is Jamaican by origin that you may not have
known the part that probably wouldn't surprise
you is.
The things that are being said by Trumpists
about Judge Chunkin on the basis that she's
Jamaican, OK?
If you go and look at the typical Trumpist
enclaves of the internet and this includes,
you know, pick your pick your enclave Facebook
comments, of course, YouTube comments certain
subreddits on Reddit, Twitter, Parler getter.
I don't even know if getyour is still around.
There are many Trumpists focused on Judge
Judkins Jamaican origin as a flashpoint of
anger and something to blame for her decision
here.
Of course, absent any evidence of that, and
some may even call that xenophobic or racist,
some may, you know, that's something I'm reading.
We're going to follow what the substance of
the Trump appeal is, and we'll know Friday
or certainly by Monday whether the committee
investigating the riots has gotten
this information.